let's bring in Sean Duffy former
Wisconsin congressman and a Fox News
contributor Sean I hope you and Rachel
and the kids had a great Thanksgiving
let's jump right into this because
Christina just mentioned what minority
leader McCarthy had to say about
possible hearings take a listen here is
what he said on that hotel down to El
Paso
and after January 3rd no longer will
members have to come down to the border
to tour we will hold our hearings at the
border so the Democrats can no longer
hide from the crisis they have created
what do you think Sean does that make uh
sense is that a good idea to do that
what will that accomplish
so first off Griff to the Jenkins family
uh Happy Thanksgiving um into all those
uh watching hope you all ate a lot of
turkey and Pie listen so Kevin
McCarthy's right so first take a step
back when when members of Congress do
things they like they've got money for a
new bridge a new road there's a policy
that makes their communities better they
actually show up and do ribbon cuttings
they love those policies and be
associated with those policies you look
at an open Southern border Democrats are
nowhere to be found right they they've
opened the Border you have streams of
people coming across which you know all
too well because you spend so much time
down there Griff but Democrats don't
want to draw attention to it they don't
have a ribbing ribbon cutting at the
border to show all the people they've
led into our country without you know
vetting or without you know permission
um they've they've excluded from their
trips going to the southern border
because they don't want Americans to see
it that's why you um you're one of the
only reporters down at the southern
border you don't see other networks at
the southern border as well so Kevin
McCarthy is doing the right thing by
saying you know what if you don't want
to come some members of Congress in the
Democrat Party what we're going to do is
we're going to actually move our
hearings out of the house and we're
going to bring them down to the southern
border so if you want to show up for
hearings you're going to come down and
see what South Texas and South Arizona
has been seeing for the last two years
of this Administration what a crisis
this border is and I think this is
really smart of the potential speaker
leader right now McCarthy to make that
play and make sure Democrats actually
have to be confronted with the problem
that they've created
you're right Sean that this
Administration certainly has nothing to
see here approach here let me show you
let's compare some Octobers we just had
an unprecedented record-breaking October
fiscal year 23 over 230 000 compared to
last year's which was the highest on
record 164 and then you go back to 21
and 20 and you can see how much those
numbers are diminishing I just put out
some information uh last week there's
more than 134 000 known gotaways we're
averaging 2
693 and so ultimately uh there there's a
strong case to be made uh by many that
my orcas has failed his job but but how
does this work you were in Congress can
they actually impeach the guy if he
won't resign because it doesn't look
like he's going to go anywhere
you know he's not going to go anywhere
so yeah they can impeach of course they
can um but that happens in the house the
impeachment but the removal proceedings
happen in the Senate and you're not
going to get a Democrat Senate to go
along with in the the removal of
Mallorca so it might be somewhat
performative but I think what's
important here Griff is drawing
attention of the of the American people
to what's happening at the southern
border unless you're a Fox News Watcher
in a Griff Jenkins fan or a bill
malusion fan you don't actually see
what's happening at the southern border
if you're watching these other networks
or these other cable channels you don't
actually grasp the seriousness of this
issue and so the drawing of attention of
the American eye to the southern border
and other news networks to the southern
border is is going to be really
beneficial in trying to get the
administration to change policy or to
change
um the head of DHS which is Mallorca so
I think that's positive but you
mentioned a year ago Griff those numbers
were outrageous it was a crisis last
year and with 65 000 more in October
this year and you talk about the
godaways when people come across you you
know they're turning themselves into
border patrol they're trying to find
Border Patrol if you're a godaway
there's something in your history
something in your past or something that
you want to do in America that you don't
want the border patrol to find you
you're not you have nefarious purposes
maybe you're a drug Smuggler You're a
murderer you're a sex trafficker you're
a terrorist but there's a reason why you
don't want to be caught those are
staggering numbers of guys that don't
want to be caught by border patrol
because they want to do us harm
um and this is a crisis completely and
good for Kevin McCarthy and these
numbers are even going to go higher when
teleporting goes away quickly in the
last 30 seconds or so I've got left I do
want to ask you about one thing and that
is Elon Musk getting a lot of attention
tweeting about he's teasing really that
he may give us some insight into the
suppression of the hunter Biden laptop
story from the New York Post putting out
a poll as well that he you know may
indeed get that public so we have some
transparency he says obviously this is
necessary to restore the public trust
your thoughts
yeah listen I think this is uh fantastic
you look at this and go was was this
really disinformation the New York Post
story on Hunter Biden or was this
Russian disinformation or did Twitter
actually know Griff that this was
strictly a straight shot of politics
we're trying to protect Joe Biden we
want to blunt Donald Trump we want to
hide this story
um I think to release what Twitter did
will give us some insight as to what
role maybe the FBI had in pushing
Twitter but also the decisions of
Twitter might also come into play what
happened at Facebook and what happened
at Google I think the American people
have a right to know on what these big
tech companies were doing to limit the
information we had about candidates as
we made a decision in 2020 because if we
can fix what happened in 2020 maybe we
can fix what happens in 2024 so we have
all the information out there as voters
on what the candidates have done and who
they are and maybe what bad things
they've done with their family to make
money off the vice presidency through
their family
and transparency is the name of the game
Sean Duffy thank you for getting up
after Thanksgiving dinner and joining us
today
thanks Greg I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm aimsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis